now missiles have struck the ukrainian
port city of odessa less than 24 hours
after ukraine and russia signed a deal
over grain exports in the black sea
ukraine's foreign ministry have
described it as a spit in the face of un
secretary general antonio gutierrez and
turkey's president erdogan it's the most
significant agreement involving the
warring parties so far russian and
ukrainian officials signed deals with
the un and turkey to resume grain
exports through the black sea to help
avert a global food crisis
our correspondent alex rossi sent this
report from dinique
what we understand is a number of cruise
missiles were fired from
the black sea some of them were
intercepted by missile defense systems
others did land
some of them we think landed in the city
but others it seems landed in the actual
port of odessa itself within the
infrastructure itself now we should
point out that the agreement
itself known as the black sea initiative
is quite limited it's a very limited and
focused ceasefire odessa itself is not
exempt from hostilities but the bits of
the port that are needed to get the
grain moving are
so
what this means exactly we don't know
but certainly i think many people are
quite rightly seeing this as extremely
cynical by the russians and an act of
really bad faith now we have had
uh some comments from the ministry of
foreign affairs here in ukraine i'll
just read uh some of it to you now
it took less than 24 hours for the
russian federation to launch a missile
attack on the port of odessa to question
the agreements and promises it made to
the un and turkey in the documents
signed yesterday in istanbul
the russian missile is vladimir putin's
spit in the face of u.n secretary
general antonio guterres and the turkish
president who made enormous efforts to
reach an agreement and to whom ukraine
is grateful
ukraine emphasizes the need for strict
implementation of the agreements
regarding the restoration of safe export
of ukrainian agricultural goods through
the black sea
ports we call on the un and turkey to
ensure that russia complies with its
obligations within the framework of the
safe functioning of the grain corridor
in case of non-fulfillment of the
agreements reached russia will bear full
responsibility for the deepening of the
global food crisis so
listening to that it would sound that
the agreement is still alive whether or
not there's still going to be a further
mediation
nobody knows now antonio gutierrez
described it as a beacon of hope a
beacon of hope he said on the on the
black sea that perhaps wasn't the best
way of describing it even yesterday more
like a flicker of hope and a flicker
that can be easily extinguished now
certainly this is very problematic for
other reasons the agreement is extremely
complicated in terms of the logistics
ultimately it's a commercial agreement
these are commercial ships that are
going to take a grain out of these ports
they also need to be insured um
cruise missiles slamming into the port
of odessa is not a particularly good
look for them is anybody going to want
to go to be involved in this deal so
that's another extremely big question
and of course if the deal falls down the
grain doesn't come out
the food crisis which is worsening in
some of the poorest countries of the
world is only going to become even more
profound